what you need to know this monday
morning begins with the latest on the
covet 19 front doug peterson joins
saints coach sean payton as the two nfl
head coaches who have tested positive
the eagles coach
tested positive over the weekend he had
two tests one positive to confirm the
first positive because they still are
concerned about false positives and
false negatives peterson is positive now
peyton went through it in the offseason
so it's not an issue now peterson
asymptomatic but still the protocols
require him to be absent from the team
for a certain period of time he'll have
to test negative twice and then he comes
back but so far so good and most of
these guys who we have seen test
positive or end up on the covet 19 list
because you don't have to test positive
to be on the list if you're in close
contact with someone who has
the the disease you automatically are
put on the list matthew stafford gardner
mint shoe
no sign that anyone is suffering any
symptoms and there are a bunch of guys
who have been placed on this list you
know for the most part they'll they'll
cycle on and cycle off and others will
go on and others will come off and this
is just going to be part of our reality
this year this short term absence
and the guy comes back
and whoever was taking his place gets
cut and it just churns and it churns and
it churns and the question is when and
if key players will be unavailable for a
game and how much advance notice a team
will have i think that's really what it
comes down to you know if doug peterson
test positive on a friday
or saturday you don't have a coach and
you didn't have a chance to plan to not
have a coach that's the key
how much time do you get to plan to not
have your coach to not have your
starting quarterback to not have some
other key player you have to plan
for the possibility that you're not
going to get to plan for any of these
guys being gone just in a moment's
notice guy's gonna be gone you got to be
ready to go that's that's part of the
reality for this season chris well it is
i mean here's your your warning shot
you're shot across the bow right here
whoa hey super bowl coach can get sick
at any time who you know have a backup
plan what's it going to be you know like
you're saying right here it could be
week five bill belichick all of a sudden
goes damn i got covered 19. all right so
have a plan who's it going to be josh
mcdaniels whatever so i think this is
something that's going to continue to be
talked about with nfl football teams for
these type of scenarios yeah you got to
figure out if you're a head coach of a
football team you know who's that guy
that you're going to have be
you know roaming the the sidelines on a
sunday to take your spot and that you
think can communicate and manage a game
all on a level that you deem acceptable
when you're not there as a head coach so
that's one good one then you get the
matthew stafford thing right and there's
another that's a warning for a starting
quarterback you better have a plan there
so uh i mean i think these are all just
little
jump offs to
open eyes through organizations to go
okay we we need to have a plan for
everything this year like you said you
never know when this virus is gonna hit
you and you know those are two fairly
big time names that would uh certainly
be affected on the play of sunday if
doug peterson or matt stafford weren't
out there for their games
more than 80 players currently are on
the covet 19 list or have been placed on
that list over the course of the last
week because some of them have already
exited gives you an idea though of of
what we're looking at here we're looking
at something that will be hanging around
the question is as these guys are with
their teams and in these facilities
which are by all accounts pristine and
and designed to limit if not eliminate
the transmission of the virus from one
person to the next will those numbers
drop or will they stay the same and the
question becomes whether to what extent
guys will catch the virus away from the
facility that's one of the concerns
right now coming up with ways to ensure
that guys don't get the virus and then
bring it to the facility and spread it
there where even though it looks like
they're doing a great job it's not
foolproof especially once you go out and
play in a game that's where it's all
going to potentially turn on its head
chris but i think that
that
they'll be able
to manage this because there are enough
guys out there who want to play football
right right now the rosters for most
teams are at 80. that means 27 will be
gone within the course of the next five
weeks those 27 per team will be
ready and willing to go and then the 10
per team that already have been shed for
the most part that's another 320 up to
320 that are going to be available it's
gonna be a lot of guys out there yes who
can fill in the question is and and i
think what it really comes down to is
an outbreak late in the week if you get
your outbreak tuesday or wednesday you
got time to plan for it and get other
players ready to go if you find out
friday saturday sunday morning
that you're down
five six seven eight guys that's when
the questions and the concerns are going
to emerge especially if it wipes out one
position group will the commissioner
pull the plug on that game that's what
that's what you know as we try to drill
down on how it can really affect the
season that's how i think it can really
affect the season friday saturday sunday
one of those three days getting the word
that a significant piece of your roster
or
almost all of one position group out on
the covet 19 list for a week or so you
got to go forward with the game while
these guys aren't available yeah well
that's going to be tricky it is i mean
because that's a player safety issue to
a degree you know i mean it is
okay yeah let's just say the tampa bay
buccaneers they have an outbreak on the
o-line on a friday all of a sudden oh
man we're only gonna have like you know
two guys that we think can actually play
we even got some backups who got an
outbreak here i mean are we gonna put
tom brady behind a bun like three other
guys that are just coming off the
streets and have no time to prepare and
all of a sudden they're playing you know
the new orleans saints or some other
really good defense with a front four
like that yeah those are gonna be you
know
uh very tough decisions that i'm glad
i'm not gonna have to make them and
that's why roger goodell is making
40-something million dollars a year
because it's not going to be easy to do
that but yeah they're going to have to
weigh those options talk to teams figure
out if the teams feel like
you know is it is it doable i think
there's going to be a lot of
conversations there but that does worry
me too mike you're right i mean that's a
real issue and i i would expect that
that does come about at some point
during the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports